the CDC has issued its highest travel
alert telling Americans to avoid all
non-essential travel to China where the
death toll from the coronavirus is
increasing video from social media shows
crowds gathering at the border of Hong
Kong where some believe they'll be safer
Hong Kong says all rail lines to
mainland China will be cut on Friday at
least 106 people have died in China
ramie Inocencio is in Beijing rainy
wonder stand the US has a flight
evacuating Americans from Wuhan yes
that's right and good morning that plane
is scheduled to take off in about 12
hours time but not every American in
Wuhan will be on it simply because there
aren't enough seats now we spoke to one
American citizen in Wisconsin a man and
he said that his wife and his kid are
stuck in Wuhan and he's hoping they are
going to get on that plane yeah are you
excited to see me Adeline yeah I miss
you too Sam Roth is doing everything he
can to help his family get out of Wuhan
his wife Daisy and his two children
Adeline and Abigail flew to China to see
Daisy's family just last week for the
big Lunar New Year holiday Sam stayed in
Wisconsin from the moment they stepped
foot on Wuhan they were told you know
stay inside don't don't get in big
gatherings and then the city went on
lockdown and they're just three of the
roughly 1,000 Americans unable to leave
they hope to be chosen to fly on the
State Department's chartered flight
Wednesday the government says priority
will be for those at greater risk we've
got a ten month old we've got a five
year old they're susceptible and they
should be prioritised US health
officials do say the virus is not
spreading widely in the country and
public danger is low still five cases
have been confirmed while more than 100
suspected cases are being tested across
26 states the American public should not
be fearful about this but you really
need to take it very seriously
because as things evolve our
recommendations in our policy will
to be in accordance with what the
evidence is back in Wuhan the city is
racing to finish two hospitals in the
next few weeks to treat thousands of
people who Hans mayor on national
television has offered to resign for
what he called an unsatisfactory
response saying about five million
people left his city before it went on
lockdown
Ramiro Senseo forests in China ramie
thank you very much